haha that move protects yeah it
stands out you don't know how animals
are gonna react even if they have their
trainers there
now i have a lot of technical issues
with the sword fight i will tell you
all right tell me
this video is sponsored by squarespace
stick around to the end to see how you
can get 10
off your first website or domain
purchase hey everybody welcome back to
another episode of
stunt people react we are joined by a
longtime friend luke lafontaine and
a new face here jessica medina luke
tends to specialize
in sword work so we're gonna be looking
at some really crazy sword fights
but jessica has a bunch of interesting
stories as well so what are some of the
projects that you've worked on well i
have something coming up in august
suicide squad too
i work on that it was so much fun and
also black adam
i am surrounded by a bunch of immense
talent and experience here
so we're going to jump into some cool
clips and these guys are going to break
them down for us
share any insights both good and bad as
to how these scenes could maybe be
better
or worse who knows it's gonna be a good
time they're the experts i'm just here
to drive this car
let's go
all right let's take a little look at
one of i think the most iconic
sword fight scenes uh maybe the past 20
years or so
there's a lot of things that are at play
here do i have issues with this fight
yeah i do but at the same time
i'm very forgiving because let me tell
you if you want to talk about one of the
hardest pieces
of fight choreography to do it would be
spear and shield
it's incredibly awkward to do
they're in skirts with no knee
protection
wearing sandals the shields let's say
those shields are solid urethane
those are heavy shields we don't have
tons of historical evidence of how the
greeks fought with spears
but there is some hundreds of years of
greek pottery
the greeks are always depicted fighting
with spears
in an overhand grip not an underhand
grip
it's an overhand grip over the shield
holding it up above the shield and
striking downwards
but we're talking about mythology
these guys aren't real so you can't
really sit there well the greeks didn't
do that
really is that kelly's a real person no
you're not dealing with two regular guys
which automatically gives you
license with a lot of the fight
choreography because these are two
people that are basically a demigod
level
so a lot of things were incorporated
into this fight there's a lot of chinese
martial arts in this fight
i really have to say i like what they
did with the kelly's fight style
achilles is very tactical and very
deliberate
about how he uses his shield they did a
great job
of keeping how he fought very uniform
within his style
they didn't they weren't all over the
map or one scene he was fighting one way
another scene he was fighting another
now the thing that's great about this
fight scene is hector is also a great
combatant
but there's an obvious story told here
that achilles is a better
warrior than hector the motivations in
this fight are totally different
achilles is blood driven in this fight
a family member of his has been slain he
wants
revenge hector is fighting in place of
his brother
so hector's motivation hector does not
have bloodlust
to kill achilles so their motivations
are entirely different
they're both very honorable warriors but
achilles motivation is more intense
than hectors and i'm a big proponent of
you've got to tell the story behind the
fight
if you just do a bunch of random sword
fight choreographer
people go oh yeah that was exciting but
i have no idea what the hell is going on
i have no idea what this guy's
motivation is there's no drama in this
so one of the things about this fight is
you get
really caught up in this you feel
something
when hector is sitting there with a
spearmint and gets that sword thrust
through his chest
you care you feel it the drama is
entirely entrenched in how this fight
was built
there also are not a bunch of silly
ridiculous
spins yeah i've always said this i
understand having to make
a fight exciting but watch john wick
you don't see somebody doing 360
pirouettes with the gun
they went and they were really really
specific about going the gun play needs
to be real in this film
the same should be true of sword fights
you choreograph this badass perfect
real fight the director comes in and
goes can he flip there
i want him to start off the fight by
doing this big sword twirl thing and
posing
and then going into the fight and i go
all right so i'm surprised we haven't
talked about this scene yet a long time
ago i asked for some comments on stunt
scenes with animals
and of course john wick chapter three
the dogs with halle berry
so you know they say when it comes to
making movies you should never work with
children you should never work with
animals
there are no babies in this scene that i
can tell but there are a bunch of
animals so when it comes to
stunt work doing stunts with animals is
that still
as hard as regular acting you don't know
how animals are going to react even if
they have their trainers there
sometimes dogs they get kind of like
carried away so i imagine you have to be
really patient
until yes work a shot be ready to be
flexible the dog
doesn't quite hit the pace it's almost
like you enter a little bit like improv
theater mixed in now
she did a lot like a lot of her stunts
because she trains with
taryn for all the gun stuff
[Music]
taran is the john wick armor gun guy so
everything you see with a gun here
is turned 100 so all those movements
with the guns the side
that's him
the the choreography and the training
and what taran puts into a gunfight
and what the 8711 guys the detail they
put into gun combat
is so intense have you done much gun
play
yeah a lot would you prefer to work with
blanks or with like
airsoft or just basic rubber props i
would say
blanks i really honestly don't like
using airsoft
it's safer but the problem is there's an
animal instinctual thing in terms of
reaction and dealing with something
where when you use real blankfire
an actor will react to the firearm
entirely differently
and it will keep them in the scene and
keep them in the reality of it
whereas when you're using airsoft you're
forcing the actor
to do all of that acting by himself
he's got to sell the firearm he's got to
sell the recoil of the gun
he's got to sell the intensity of being
in the middle of a gunfight
there's a reaction that happens to you
know your face like if somebody claps
their hand right in front of you and
yeah
you kind of do that that's a that's a
thing that gets missed like
90 of the time that people film with
like airsoft guns or fake guns it's just
that little
that your face does involuntarily when
loud noises are happening in front of
you
if you guys are enjoying these videos we
do one every saturday please consider
subscribing to the channel if you are
not
it helps us out and helps you watch the
videos
the duelist demands satisfaction honor
for him is an appetite
an obsession to kill now amongst the
sword community
this movie is one of the holy grails in
terms of being one of the first
films to really depict the
danger and deadliness of
real steel blades in a sword fight and
the combatants they went above and
beyond in terms of making you feel
two men facing each other with razor
sharp steel
and one of them could die
and when you watch this there's a bunch
of false starts
why these two guys are nervous keith
carradine's character does not want to
be in this sword fight
he doesn't want to be there he's scared
shirtless
and that's depicted in their technique
and what they're doing nobody's jumping
in
there isn't suddenly 30 click clacks of
swords here
boom he just got stuck that's about the
length of a realistic sword fight
now what happened is he's just had three
feet of steel
rammed through the outer part of his
pectoral muscle
if you look at small swords it's a
triangular blade
it's not diamond shaped a thin
diamond-shaped blade
the wound will close up a triangular
small sword blade
the wound never closes properly what
always happened was
a piece of the cotton or linen or silk
shirt
was pressed into the wound and left in
there
now what happens to shirts you get
sweaty and stinky
and all kinds of nasty stuff gets on
your shirt that's now been pressed
inside of your wound
a lot of these guys got sepsis so you'd
think oh i survived the sword duel
you go home you lay in bed the wound
doesn't heal correctly the wound gets
horribly infected
so in a simple sword duel like that it
cost you your life
so when you look at the physicality
between these two guys
keith is trying to survive harvey keitel
is a madman
and he's fighting with abandon and when
you watch this sword fight
harvey keitel loses because he's not
protecting himself
all he wants to do is chop big chunks
out of
keith carradine and as a result it gets
sloppy
which really happens in sword fights
because your emotion gets involved
you get pissed you don't keep yourself
under control
and what happens is keith carradine's a
better swordsman
harvey cartel cuts wide keith comes to
the inside
and cuts his wrist open the minute he
cussed open his wrist
they grow all your your control tendons
in your wrist
the minute he does that he sucks and
punches harvey can tell across the face
with the knuckleball of his saber ending
the sword fight
this is actually a real technique this
is what happens you don't have people
lopping people's heads off and cutting
people in half because in a real life or
death
situation i promise you you wouldn't do
any of those
i've never seen a flap of skin in a
sword fight
this is the out of all the sword fights
and movies i've never seen just a simple
i sliced you and there's a flap hanging
yeah it's exactly what happens you know
i've been
cut by swords and knives i can tell you
it's not fun oh really nothing
i mean look i i there's nothing you know
i got into some things when i was a
younger man
i've been stabbed wow if you have a
choice
between being cut or being stabbed trust
me you want to be cut
when you are stabbed you're punctured
all the percussive energy goes into your
body into your muscles into the bone
the amount of pain when the initial stab
happens
and the amount of pain for months
afterwards is it's immeasurable
if somebody rams a sword through your
torso
you're not going to keep sword fighting
your body
momentarily shuts down and cramps up
around the blade
there's so much trauma being done you
can't sit there and go ha ha
and just keep sword fighting like errol
flynn it just doesn't happen
i wish that there were more films out
there
that did their homework watched this
movie understood what the intent was
understood the art understood what this
film accomplished
and tried to replicate that
[Music]
time for perhaps the most iconic sword
fight scene of all time
princess bride
this sword fight unabashedly replicates
the old swashbuckling films of the 1930s
arrow flint our own power it brilliantly
captures
old classic hollywood i am not my friend
i'm not left-handed either there's a
storyline built in here of silly
one-upmanship
there are a bunch of things that are
done in this for the sake of
comedic storyline points so there's a
little bit like buster keaton going on
in this
now i have a lot of technical issues
with the sword fight i will tell you
all right tell me i love hearing the
technical issues with it i love hearing
the historical mistakes he doesn't make
this hard fight any worse it's not
detracting from the sword fight
at no point did these guys say hey
we're trying to do a completely period
historical reenactment
of a rapier fight nobody ever said that
first and foremost
the swashbuckling films of the 1930s
which were brilliantly choreographed by
ralph faulkner
and fred cavens they were fencing
masters
not historical sword fight masters
you're looking at saber technique
this isn't correct technique for a
rapier it's flashier
if these two guys were to try and
replicate a real period rapier fight
it wouldn't look the same at all you're
thrusting with a rapier you're not
cutting
and there'd be a lot of blades whizzing
by heads and moving by torsos and
realistically in a fight of this length
they both would have been stuck two or
three times
this is a swashbuckling fight so you can
see all of the tic tacs
and the click clacks and the flashy cuts
that are being made
this isn't how rapiers are used another
odd thing
that i didn't really agree with but they
did in this fight the blades
are very short you can see that these
swords are only about 30 inches long
a real rapier is going to have a blade
anywhere from 34
to 40 inches long wesley
sword is not really a rapier it's got a
rapier blade in it
but the hilt is this kind of made up
mishmash thing rapiers have
what's called a ricasso where the small
arms of the hill
leave a section for you to loop your
finger through
wesley's sword doesn't have that so
wesley
is gripping his sword in a saber grip
whereas
inigo montoya is gripping his sword like
a rapier hmm
[Music]
there's something this doesn't make any
sense mandy potemkin's sword
is on top of carrie elways
he could easily take that sword and
flick it right up into carrie always
face
and cut his entire cheek and his eye
open that's a
small technicality that i kind of looked
at and i went
yeah man you gotta let that go but if
you're gonna be technical about it these
are little teeny
historical whiny nitpicky things this
was
months and months and months of work
and you want to give the respect that
everybody busted their ass on this piece
yeah and i think they did a great job
with it there's the 1930s and this was
done decades later
now people look at this as one of the
classic sword fights
and i'm going well yeah technically that
makes me feel old but yeah
i hear that the internet's going to be a
big deal and you can get into that game
with your very own website what websites
don't i need like a degree in medicine
or something like that to be able to
build one of those i hear they're
complicated to which i respond
well have you ever tried using
squarespace.com they offer award-winning
templates make building website easy
what squarespace i've never heard about
that what is that squarespace has lots
of great product features you have
member areas we can connect with the
audience and generate revenue through
gated members only content
squarespace also makes it easy to put
videos into your website and they even
have extra features to make sure that
your pages load quickly
even if videos are embedded in them also
you can connect your social media
accounts very easily letting you display
posts
from your website onto your social media
automatically
you can have multiple contributors on
your website squarespace makes it easy
to give
multiple contributors selective access
to different areas of your website so
that you can have everybody managing
their own specific content if you want
great insights into all of your
statistics and knowing where your
traffic is coming from
how many unique visitors you have what
pages they're watching all that is
easily available too because knowledge
is
power now you might think that when
you're uploading all this to squarespace
there's some
weird little clause and a contract that
says that squarespace owns some of it
squarespace does not
own any of the content that you upload
you own 100
of everything you upload squarespace
does not own it and they offer one-click
data portability meaning it's easy
to copy your data back off of
squarespace's servers onto your hard
drives
if you are in the market for a website
or domain definitely give squarespace a
shot they actually offer a bunch of
great services
and if you click the link in the
description below you can get 10
off your first website or domain
purchase and they also offer a free
trial so go check it out squarespace.com
corridor crew link is in the description
below happy website building
jake i hope i did you proud let me know
all right back to the video no matter
what sitting down on this couch i always
learn something new
jessica luke thank you so much for
joining us both of these guys have a
whole bunch more
cool things to show you so you can
actually check out jessica's instagram
at jessica median actress i'll have a
link in the description below
you can check out my instagram page i
also did life of action volume 2 which
was put out by mike fury
which is a great book about stunt
performers in the industry
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you guys in the next video
i mean hey probably one coming out
tomorrow saturdays and sundays those are
our days
all right see in the next one